على كل المزيد معنا ليله بازاري تحديدا من
سراييف ومن البوسنه ليث اهلا بك من احد
المخابز التقليديه هناك حيث يتم الاقبال
على الخبز البوسني تحديدا في رمضان تفضل
مساء الخير لكما مساء الخير نديم مساء
الخير بالسهام وطبعا
بعدنا بالاكل اليوم الصمون
البوسطي في ساعه الغروب يهرع سكان سراييفو
الى هذه المخابز التقليديه هنا في البلد
القديمه لشراء خبز الصمون سيمون بسموهن
الذي يرافق المائده الرمضانيه في جميع
البيوت البوسنيه خبز التمور اذا مثل ما
بنشوف يعني هو مكون من الدقيق والخميره
والماء والملح وحبه البركه ويوضع في فرن
موقد بالحطب لينضج على درجه حراره عاليه
شوب كثير هون تصل الى 500 درجه مئويه
وتترك العجينه مده مده دقيقه واحده
مكسيموم في الفرن حتى نحصل على هذا الخبز
وطبعا يعني حرفه
توارثها الابناء عن الاجدادهم
وقد افتتحت مخابز عده في السنوات الاخيره
التي اعقبت سنوات الحرب هنا في البوسنه
والهرسك كما حاولت المدن البوسيه الاخرى
تقليد مخابز هذه المخابز بعمل هذا الخبز
التقليدي ولكن لم يستطيعوا للاسف الا انها
عجزت عن اتقانه وكذلك الحال في دول
البلقان الاخرى مثل مقدونيا وكوسوفو
والجبل الاسود ويعمل الخباز اللي بنشوفه
في الصوره هون الخبازين يعملون لساعات عده
اتصل الى 15 ساعه يوميا تخيلوا وتصل
المبيعات اليوم الواحد الى اكثر من الف
رغيف هذا اللي نشوفه بالكاميرا الثانيه
الف رغيف يوميا يقومون بصناعه في شهر
رمضان على الاقل على كل حال هي الاقبال
على هذا الخبز ليس فقط من قبل المسلمين
الذين يشكلون طبعا 85% من السكان ولكن غير
المسلمين ياتون خصيصا لشراء هذا الخبز بدي
احاول بالكاميرا الثانيه اقطع الكاميرا
الاولى واجرب اورجيكم
الطوابير خارج الفرن ينتظرون هم ليسوا
جميعا المسلمون مره اخرى والكثير منهم
ينتظر بشراء هذا الخبز التقليدي او السمول
البوسني واذا حكينا كمان عن يعني
بخلاف انواع اخرى من الخبز والمعجنات يمكن
هذا الخبز او الصمون يكون ايام عده ويبقى
رطب وهذا طبعا شيء نادر بنعرف ان العجين
والخبز دائما لا يكون رطبا لفتره طويله
وتقتض يعني هذه المخابز بالصائمين وغيرهم
البوسنيات وكذلك الصرب والكويت وسكان
مونتينيغرو او الجبل الاسود ورغم ان
الاقبال على شراء الصامون يزداد في شهر
رمضان الا ان تلك المخابز تبيع هذا الخبز
طيله ايام السنه حيث يتناول مع الكباب
البوسني الشهير تمتد طبعا طوابير مثل ما
شفنا قبل شوي بطول الشارع على مدار الشهر
باكمله ويتناول الصائمون يسمون مع شوربه
التوبا التوبه هي شوربه هنا محليه وهي
عباره عن مزيج من القشطه والحليب والجبنه
والزبده الزبده السائله طبعا تخلط مع
بعضها ثم توضع على نار هادئه وتؤكل ساخره
هذا الحلو بالموضوع يعني ابان حصار صريف
وقت ما حكينا بالعناوين وهو الحصار الاطول
في تاريخ الحرب الحديثه
ايضا باننا ننقل لكم اجواء شهر رمضان يعني
حتى في مدن ومناطق اوروبا الشرقيه ننقل
لكم يعني توجه موفد مساء العربيه الى
سراييفو حيث يوجد هناك اكثر من 60% تقريبا
من سكانها هم من المسلمين حيث نتابع معكم
اجواء شهر رمضان وليس ينقل لنا كيفيه
صناعه هذا الخبز الصمون المشهور من احد
المخابز القديمه على كل حال احنا بنستنى
الافطار يا نادين حتى نتناول هذا هذا
الخبز الصمون يعني
حابب كثير هيك اتناول خبزه واكلها رقصه
مباشره على الهواء ولكن بالانتظار الافطار
اكيد راح يكون بعد ساعه ونصف الساعه اقل
بعد نصف ساعه من الان سيكون موعد الافطار
السابعه والنصف مساء بتوقيت
اوروبا راح يكون الافطار في هذه المدينه
وطبعا بدنا نقول لك يا سهام صحه فطوركم
ياريتكم كنتوا معنا او ياريتكم موجودين
معنا حتى ناكل هذا السمون واي شيء معه
اوكي بكون طيب اكيد
اصلا باقي معنا كل الاسبوع يا ليس لتنقل
لنا اجواء ايضا العشر الاواخر من البوسنه
من العاصمه الصرايف شكرا لك
شكرا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات